Sandra Pearson knows the pain and
frustration of delayed discharge my
sister and I were in tears on more than
one occasion it's heartbreaking
absolutely heartbreaking her mother Ava
who has dementia was ready to leave
Hospital nine days after a fall but it
was a further 96 before she was able to
leave when we were eventually able to go
in it was such a shock
we just couldn't believe how mum looked
she lost over two stone in weight
in the time that she was there
um but also she she her personality had
changed we found several care homes that
she could have gone to but they didn't
act upon it quickly enough and by the
time they did mum's Behavior
deteriorated so she wasn't they wouldn't
take her it's an issue the PM says he's
determined to sort the number one
problem we've got at the moment is that
around 13 000 people in hospitals who
ideally should be back in their
communities in Social care or home
settings and recently we've put an extra
half a billion pounds in over this
winter in a discharge fund the
government are now expected to spend
hundreds of millions of pounds block
buying Care Home beds and if it all goes
to plan some claim the effects could be
felt within weeks I've been working only
the last 22 years and I've never seen
anything like this while this emergency
medicine consultant welcomes more
investment he argues the alternative is
unnecessary deaths we need a solution
immediately we need this to be uh
reviewed as a crisis and the NHS put in
a crisis footing because we know that
for every 82 patients who wait more than
six to eight hours in a e waiting for a
walled bed and extra patient dies within
30 days and this is a preventable death
and if we're not going to sort this out
an unnecessary 300 to 500 people every
single week will die in English
hospitals because of the these delays in
emergency care so the health services
not just on its knees it's on its face
meanwhile labor concede if they get into
Power private companies will play a part
of the private sector in the NHS under
labor yes but I mean let me be clear
we're not talking about privatizing the
NHS we're used we're talking about using
the private sector effectively
um and free at the point of use is an
absolutely governing Principle as we go
into this review but we do need change
and reform but pay and conditions Remain
the most pressing problem for the NHS
tomorrow as Steve Barkley meets Health
unions doctors will be balloted on
Industrial action and ambulance workers
due to strike later in the week Joe Pike
Sky News Westminster